[Music]
the day after the surgery
I got invited to the US Open and I was
like [__] yeah I'm gonna go to the US
Open
and I'm walking around and I'm like this
is like golf Coachella like the dust
there's thousands of people walking
around this golf course that's just dirt
yeah
and it just looked all you can see is
brown fog and like the number one rule
was like don't go anywhere Dusty or
dirty
and for like three hours so I left
because I was like hey this is I'm
playing I don't want to you know I don't
wanna [__] my eyes but for the next
three hours I had dirt like caked in my
tear ducts because I know some got in
there
but I got these drops and antibiotic
drops and everything's fine but being at
the US Open was [__] sick Jon Rahm
drove at 350 yards right in front of us
no it was sick John wrong John ROM oh no
way it's not like he's gonna [__] it's
not like he drives the one of the
fastest race cars on earth and he's got
a huge [__]
oh Louis Hamilton no dude me
well you might find this interesting
I found this I found this out afterwards
so that this is the first time that the
LA Country Club has like ever hosted
anything any golf event that's like on
tour or whatever since like 1942 or
something like that this piece of land
that this that the 36 holes is on and
the clubhouse is worth eight billion
dollars wow because right in the middle
of Beverly Hills xqc could buy like one
hole yeah exactly
the country club itself
only has 800 members
the Initiation fee is 250 Grand just to
get in to die just to die
and uh why is that the number for these
things yeah what's going on
quarter Mill
but anyways so like you know
traditionally I think they like wouldn't
let like Jewish people in or black
people was like very racist yeah and
then oh
you also couldn't get in if you were a
celebrity or at any way related to like
the entertainment world oh so multiple
different massive celebrities have
bought houses on the course and been
denied admission including Hugh Hefner
built the Playboy Mansion got denied
entry and so he as Revenge he built a
zoo
as part of the Playboy mansion that's
why he built the zoo part and so on one
of the holes you can hear like animals
like you know like lions and [__] in the
background wow
I thought it was interesting I like how
exclusive
you know maybe the racist part kind of
sucks but I don't think it's like that
anymore but it's still like you can't
it's like multi-year-long like vetting
process they go through every aspect of
your life yeah I just kind of like that
their blanket just this is one of the
last things that influencers cannot have
yeah no it is one of the few things they
can have yeah it says no celebrities
that's like one of the rules agents
calling in yeah I got my guy here little
honey look he's a he's a major star we
don't know no yeah that phone slamming
on the hook yeah no
[__] they still got a phone on a hook
in there
yeah probably yeah thank you for calling
Beverly Hills Country Club so that's
where you were like the dress code is
crazy it's like no denim ever so so
that's where you went this is where the
US Open was yeah and you got to go for
the first time yeah
and uh like an hour you perused yeah it
was sick they also uh Malcolm Gladwell
did an episode a couple years ago about
La country clubs on her visionist
history and they are able to skirt
property taxes that's another thing way
less like a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year because of some
proposition that was passed through by
Bob Hope in 1960 and they use it to like
yeah basically pay almost nothing this
land is worth eight billion dollars so
property taxes should be 80 million a
year but it's appraised at like 300 000
300 000 wait for the whole land that's
what they pay
yeah so it's appraised at like 30
million or whatever that is
um it's insane
it would be a shame if someone started
pooping on it
that's not a callback that's a call
forward yep
would be a shame attemptive joke
would be same if someone just started
pooping on the same hole on weekdays
oh how would they do that that's a good
question
oh no one of the 800 exclusive players
found poo poo in the hole again
wonder how that happened oh no the
little diarrhea get on your Titleist
golf ball
wow
yikes golf is cool all right it is no
yeah no I believe it it is [__] cool
yep and uh
no it actually is cool I was a dude I
was standing there on the side of the
hole just praying one of those guys just
shakes it right into my face you know
yeah and then it would be cool and it
didn't happen yeah just my smiling face
yeah they think they give you a glove if
they hit you with a golf do they
free glove you're like unrecognizable
lose all your teeth your jaws all [__]
up I think that's what people think of
free gloves and Formula One races too
like oh it'd be so cool if this car just
shanked right here and just crashed into
like killed all of us
no you know what psycho to me about
formula one is
because the cars are like fiberglass and
just like so paper thin sometimes like
chunks of the car will just like go
skidding somewhere
and when the race is over
everyone's allowed to like run down onto
the track to the like to the Celebration
Podium and like watch them get the
trophies and stuff I believe it's like
during that period people will hop the
fence and go running up the track
because they spotted a piece of car hmm
just snatch it Jesus it's sick I mean
yeah there are so many people with does
it ever like hit the audience
um I think usually the protection is
like high enough that it doesn't
um
but I'm sure there's like been episodes
of that because I'm surprised there's
not like more deaths at a golf
tournament because it's like
there's like thousands and thousands of
people lining the holes
like have you ever played golf with
anyone like Shanks happen all the
[__] time and it just goes into
different parts of the course but like
in this case you can't and we watch like
we will probably watch eight Pros take
their second shot on the first on the
first hole and not a single one of them
was even close to hitting anyone um
but you'd think it would happen all the
time so this is what I mean like this is
what it's like just hundreds of people
and this is lined up on the side right
he's a YouTuber you know they but he's
really good
I would let Gary hit me with the ball
I'm not gonna lie
and it hits a woman what
oh
that's what I'm saying dude all right
wait for it
oh yeah right overhead
funk
yep look at that Jesus this is that
[__] unidentified UAP video
yeah
we've got another video of a UAP that's
another preemptive joke yeah sorry
whoops